like on the forehead. Didn't get I'm not
knocked out. And then he tries to pull
me over here.
Scuffle on the floor.
Some stuff happens. I think someone paid
this guy to do that. I think someone
paid him
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the grace. Brothers and
sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway where there's
so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This Masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this Masjid
inshallah. A new project that's only of
us give 1 lb, 10 lb, 100 lb, 1,000 lb,
that's going to be something you will
never regret on
and everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds on
are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the As-salamu alaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Please inshallah before that guy
subscribe to our new channel Let's Play
a Game. We've got amazing guests podcast
is a show game with personal questions
and cards. Our next guest tomorrow is
Canyon which is already been
pre-recorded and filmed. We've had
hijab. We had my baby brother.
I'm going to have some amazing amazing
guests. We have
So the next episode is tomorrow Canyon.
Let's get straight to the video
inshallah. We're going to go on X and
see the world reacting to
the dirtbag who punched brother Sneako
out of nowhere a sucker punch. So as you
can see the coward and if I'm not
mistaken he maced him
and ran off which is a coward you can
see.
God knows who sent him.
I'm not going to make any speculations
but let's go to the video as inshallah.
Hit me clean. He got me like on the
forehead. Didn't get I'm not knocked
out. So look, he's already ready to
swing. He's already ready to swing.
Yeah, you can see. So you can see this
is why it's it's a very important
obviously
situation awareness as well. It's a
reminder to Sneako as well that I'm a
public figure as well to be wary. Do you
get what I'm trying to say?
And be alert all the time and also one
thing that I did message brother Sneako
as well on WhatsApp that to do his
morning and evening
that is to protect you against evil eye,
black magic, and physical harms as well
unless what Allah wills. So what Allah
wills will reach you. So what other than
that it's so important as a public
figure
your morning and evening has to be done
and not just public figures. You guys at
home protect yourself against envy,
jealousy, black magic,
you name it. Okay.
Evil eye
and even physical harms with the morning
and evening you can find that on our app
Pro. It's for absolutely free no
subscription. We're a charity. The app
belongs to the you guys have donated
towards it. Let's carry on.
He didn't hear what I was saying. He
identified it. He knew where I was. So
Some people are saying it's a street
cipher.
He's already ready.
So he hits me.
Didn't hit me clean. He got me like on
the forehead. Didn't get I'm not knocked
out. And then he tries to pull me over
here.
Scuffle on the floor.
Some stuff happens. I think someone paid
this guy to do that. I think someone
paid him
to do this. And you can see Sneako looks
fantastic. I mean he's just back on the
show like nothing. Sneako
but you can see
and in that situation you can't do
nothing. You've been hit. Your day's
out. You know it could be for a split
second you could be unconscious for a
split second. You don't know there's not
much that could be done in that
situation.
You'll see the footage.
But there's just no way. We'll figure it
out. You okay? Yeah.
Don't I look okay? Calvin said I heard
heard you say Tyson. Well, I didn't get
knocked out.
But I mean even if you did not get
knocked out that's that's I mean that's
no blame at all. You know what I mean?
It's just a sucker punch come from out
of nowhere and you look I mean he looks
I'll be honest with you. He looks
absolutely fine. Like if if I didn't see
that I would not have think he got
punched.
Tyson
Especially too if you're going to if
you're going to do a sucker punch like
that that's some [__] [__]
[__] behavior. Like just do a a sucker
punch like that I'm not looking. I'm
looking at the chat. It could have been
way worse.
I'm glad that it didn't go worse but
I'm looking good. You know what the fact
that he remembers Allah and saying
praise be to Allah, you know,
it does show that the vicar of Allah is
on his tongue. You know just saying it
could have been worse etc. Looking at
the positive, you know, of the situation
at and let's see. Okay, so here's a
video of So we've got people here. This
guy, American Papa Bear whatever it's
called kick streamer Sneako gets sucker
punched out of nowhere while live on
stream by random guy. I have a feeling
that he later
he later loved it because it it
it is great content for his page and he
likely earned a lot from it. Anything
for clicks for guys. How did How do you
know American flipping Papa
Papa Pig? Yeah, I don't know what the
hell you're talking about. So let's
carry on.
Um okay, what do we have here? Okay, so
here is a clip. We don't know if it's
said here but Andrew Tate gives his
thoughts on Sneako getting sucker
punched today. Sneako is a weak man with
no social awareness. A real man would
have assessed the danger level and
protected themselves. Like you know
Okay, he shouldn't have done that. Okay.
But to call him a weak man, I mean you
had situation awareness when you was in
that boxing ring and you ended up on the
floor. You know, I used to You actually
was fully flirting going for that, you
know, and the way you performed I'll be
honest with you.
Let's let's be real here. Your situation
awareness, my friend, you knew the whole
situation beforehand etc. On the day and
as a person who's a fighter who has
experience fighting fighting someone
like your opponent and ended up on the
floor like that. Come on, if anything to
be blamed is is you Andrew Tate because
you are you are a fighter. Sneako is not
Sneako. He does training etc. We've
trained with him in
boxing training here and there when he
came to London in Ramadan a couple of
years ago. But if anything, you know,
you should be blamed worthy because you
are someone who's in the sports. Yeah,
so let's go. Okay. Okay, so here is
interesting. So daily halal KO
is capturing. So let's just watch this
for ourselves cuz it seems interesting.
It seems like two people took a picture
of him.
Like how do they do that? How do the
birds all know to fly in the same
direction in circle
without speaking to each other?
And New York City is an example of that
school of fish or flock of birds.
You've got the first guy there who took
a picture. Okay.
Hey, what's up?
Come on, guys.
[__] just took a picture of him.
All right.
Okay, I don't make much of that because
people can take pictures. I'm I'm a
public figure and people take pictures.
So yeah, I don't make much of that. But
I just want to see Andrew Tate's
comment on this because he did say
something.
Clavicula is reacting to Sneako getting
punched. So let's see what he had to
say.
Sneako got what?
What are you talking Sneako knocked
Wait. Hold on. Did he actually?
Wait, Sneako just got attacked. He
deserves to be publicly executed. Yes.
What?
What are we talking about?
>> [snorts]
>> Oh, hell no.
What the [__]
What the [__] was that?
Put your life for a second.
Dude, what
the [__]
Oh, it's like
Yo, that's [__] bro. [snorts]
I mean
he is
he doesn't seem happy about it. But
Andrew Tate has a different whole
different reaction. So Sneako is
obviously replying to those who are
laughing at the situation. Let's just
watch that for ourselves.
Like Jason, that reaction.
Best believe, man, if it happened to me
why do you not think that could happen
to you, too?
What? Because you think that my rhetoric
is worse? Do you even know what it is?
What's Jason saying? Oh, because you put
up one hand?
That stuff's a joke.
Second, there are a lot of other people
out there that don't like what you say
as well. There are a lot of people that
think that you're wrong.
There are a lot of other people that
might also pay somebody to do something
like that.
You found it a funny but
best believe if you're a public figure
like that, if you're speaking up, if
you're talking about what's going on in
the world, which I do I've been
very publicly anti Iran war.
Public about wanting unity especially
between Christians and Muslims.
If people disagree with that, you can
see what happened to me.
A lot of people disagree with you.
Best believe
it could happen to you, too. That's
true. It can happen to anyone. It can
happen to anyone.
Okay, I don't know who Ed Matthews is
but let's see what he had to say.
Oh my god.
You random dummy just punched Sneako in
the air. Was it a good hit or not a good
hit?
Who cares, man? Look at the first thing.
Was it a good hit? Yeah, and this is
this is so sad that it's come back down
to was it a good hit? Was it a bad hit?
Who cares, man? A human being has been
attacked. What the hell are you talking
about a good hit or bad hit?
So there is this comment which you can
see but I don't know if it was made
recently. I'm so glad we don't have to
be nice to Sneako anymore from some guy
called Feels Guy.
Wish I threw him under the bus twice.
[__]
N I G or whatever it's for that matter.
So So like I said, guys, so you can see
what the internet is saying about it.
There are people who are obviously
happy about it. There are people who are
not happy about it. But that is besides
the point, guys. The point here is
is that behind it behind this is
anything can happen anytime. Brothers
and sisters, like that could be a punch.
That could be the angel of death. This
is one thing we need to understand with
these kind of stuff. Brothers and
sisters, that the angel of death could
have come to him or anyone for that
matter. You could be walking down the
road. You could have plans. I'm going to
go tomorrow. I'm going to do this. I'm
going to do that. Next thing you know
it's the angels asking you who is your
Lord?"
Out of nowhere. Bro, you had plans. I
was going to go holiday. I was going to
buy a car. I was going to get married.
Bro, I was going to have a kid. I was
going to have this. I was going to have
that. I was saving up for this.
Bye-bye.
Who is your Lord?
It's as simple as that. Who is your
Lord?
And then the matter is closed.
Then it's like, "Yo,
you know, everything you worked for,
everything you done, and now it's a
matter of the day of judgment."
So, yeah, brothers and sisters. So,
subhanallah, make yourselves ready,
subhanallah, cuz you do
come. It could be anytime. This is just
a punch that happened. It took him by
surprise. Imagine the shock you're going
to be in when you've just run into it.
That could be me, bro. I could be
walking down the road. Somebody could
just throw a punch. Someone could throw
a knife. Someone could shoot me.
The shock is there. Do you get what I'm
trying to say? But the biggest shock is
imagine you're walking down the road,
anything,
dead.
Dead. Gone.
And then you wake up to not your friends
and family and this day it's okay. You
just go here. You just walk up. No, no.
You're dead, my friend. You've left the
world.
Done.
Now you're questioned, bro, everything
you did.
Like Allah says in the Quran,
every little deed of good, every little
deed of bad you've done
is going to be shown.
It's going to be shown.
Brothers and sisters,
invest where it matters. Wallahi, the
people you try to please, your mom, your
Look, look, look, look, I understand
parents.
Friends, family, wallahi, the moment you
are buried, they're on their phones.
Brother, you're long forgotten.
Forgotten.
Invest where it matters because believe
me, the only one that cares about you is
Allah. And I try my best to make it
priority
above my kids, my wife, my mother, my
father, my siblings, is Allah. I'm
telling you clearly. I try my best to
put Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
before anyone, including my children and
my kids, cuz Allah says, "Your spouses
and your children will be a trial and a
fitna from you. You will see enemies
from them." So, believe me, the only one
that's loyal to you is Allah and his
messenger. May Allah protect all of us.
Nico, please do your adkhar, brothers
and sisters. Download the Salah Pro app.
Please, please do your adkhar,
inshallah, brothers and sisters. Till
next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.